[Music]  you watching the film on that yeah  i've been showing it well you can't even  see it that well  that's why i just turn up the button  there's no surround sound either hello  what there's no surround sound on that  what do you want to do i don't got a  stick my nostrils  there's also no popcorn no concessions  uber  you know you love concessions exactly  watching the movie in the theater is  very exciting no all right you're right  you're right  hang on  oh my god is that all right have you  ever let me about going to venue as well  i mean that depends would the experience  be better  why you got to be the voice of reason  because i'm a lover of the arts you're a  lover of being a pain in mind get on the  train and see movies the way they're  supposed to be seen just stab me watch  bullet train in imax